today's video is sponsored by surfshark
vpn
you gotta have a little bit of great in
your voice
okay so this is from uh bachelorette and
barry
this is one of the contestants he's
going to talk to her uh basically after
something
some kind of special event happened on
this i told you from the beginning i'm
gonna be open
honest and yeah you know only thing that
i ask is really that you just hear me
out and
of course you know you just you give me
a chance to say all that i have to say
absolutely i mean i feel like you got a
lot to say so yeah so yeah
again i said there's been a couple red
flags that this kind of came out to me
and there's been a couple of red flags
there was a little bit of anger
underneath her face red flag
i could feel that anger ceiling you ever
hear like a teapot slowly start to like
start seeing
that's what you feel basically said that
um you know
like you guys are here for me okay and
you're 100 correct we are here for you
but
like you're here for us too yeah it's
it's it's two-sided
and i've sacrificed a lot to be here i'm
missing out on time with my daughter
yeah
and every second i'm here that's one
second i've taken away from being with
my my child
honestly i get it my mom is dying yeah
i'm sorry
it's not about you you was talking about
why you got
if you're saying you're trying to listen
listen yeah
but bringing it to you sometimes just
makes it like
but i might be wrong i might be wrong i
might be super old and you may not
understand what he's actually going
through to
already assume that you get it you may
not let me continue
i'm sorry let me continue i totally want
to thank you thank you um
i was absolutely appalled
at the group date that occurred
yesterday there's
good guys you know doing airplane dodge
ball together
it's so humiliating and degrading and i
don't see how that
really translates into finding a husband
i feel like i want to up the ante here
all right i think we should play
dodgeball
oh what okay
so yeah they were basically in thongs
and then they were made to dance around
to go do dodgeball and she asked to take
more off yeah well they were in shorts
and she's like all right take it all off
yeah
like if my daughter saw me doing that my
family saw me doing that like think of
the thoughts they would have
think of think of think of the example
that would be setting that's why you
were not on that date
well oh wow
she went from i understand to petty yeah
i'm seriously glad i wasn't i was so
appalled
a completely classless display i
expected a lot more from the oldest
bachelorette that's ever been
and i i can't believe i can't believe
that
that actually occurred that's not the
type of example i want set for my
daughter
i'm ashamed to be associated with you i
can't believe i sacrificed
so much to be here he's squishy because
he's like yo listen
okay i was just telling you was i i felt
you replied with petty all right well
i'ma go all in
but also then he's setting the wrong
example for his daughter you know he's
been criticizing her for setting the
wrong example for his daughter
in terms of her behavior but now once
she gets petty he decides to jump in the
dirt with the pig and also get dirty
that's not a good example he said either
so by his own ethics and his own
standards
i'm disagreeing with what he's saying
now okay if he would have walked away
right there
my man would have looked like the
champion yeah now he's trying to
point he's trying to go back because
he'll be yeah he might feel good to be
like yeah i told that
but you don't actually win going back to
our first date
i feel like you like really overreacted
honestly it sounded a little crazy oh
she's crazy she's about to lose it
like what sounded crazy what about me
saying that
i want guys who are here for me i'm
looking for a husband i'm looking for
someone to love
me i'm looking for something i've
listened to you no no this entire time
i would never want my children having a
father like you get out of here remember
you're almost 40
remember you're almost 40.
he went full petty he went all over
yeah you went um you're almost 40
hag
he went there this guy oh wow you went
there
damn today's video is sponsored by
surfshark
vpn a vpn is just an application or a
web extension that you could use
on your internet browser to mask your ip
address to change
the location of your ip you might be
like yo but i like where i live
the block is hot what happens when you
want to watch a tv show
and it says we don't offer it to people
in your country what you going to do
who are you going to call not
ghostbusters right i was trying to watch
a tv show in the uk so i was like hey
man let me in
i just said no no nobody from canada so
i changed my ipa address using
surfsharkvpn
all of a sudden brev i'm from brixton
wagon and now if you sign up with the
promo code
abba and preach you get 84 percent off
for the next four months
because it's black friday deals and i'm
a black man so i got y'all some extra
special
because right now the deal is on the
table but the tables off the deal
because i ain't giving you the table
with the deal
or no deal
can you deal with that
i had no other rhymes talking to a woman
like that i don't care what was done
i don't care what i've done i didn't
even do anything to that man
sick sick to sit there and say you're
the oldest bachelor and guess what i'm
the oldest bachelorette this 39 that's
standing here this single
because i didn't settle for men like
that
i'm see it going i'm proud okay we get
it cool cool
if you just yell it in the mirror long
enough maybe you'll believe it one day
she sounded like one of those self-help
books i'm
single not because i am difficult
but because i didn't settle for men like
that
say it again sister no you single
because you don't know how to act who
raised you
it's a bachelor it's already just just
putting yourself out there and competing
like that on the open just
it's just one side of how meh it is
so yeah yeah there's a way to do it in
some kind of way and some kind of
but just the fact that you're competing
you're putting yourself
against other people so of course
there's going to be some stabbing
there's going to be some low characters
and stuff like that
and there's going to be some you know
hypocrisy stuff no
so yeah that is a way to do it yeah
there's a way to do it but i mean at the
end at the beginning
just at the basis of this whole thing is
the how it's based on what you're gonna
it's just wack and just shallow so yeah
there's a way to do it not to disrespect
the person
but just the fact that you're competing
in this whole i don't have to compete
against people it's either you want me
or you don't if you don't it's all good
i'm leaving i'm bouncing i'm good
but you are technically competing and
she's not direct but it's not just that
in that way and televised and making it
into an arena which is fun
which which was degrades the whole thing
when you lower
and that's to me maybe like i'm like
old-fashioned or whatever
not but just the fact that you go like
that and you put yourself out there
and you compete in front of people you
do these
uh events you do all these little events
and little
challenges to it's whack it's what i
guess we do it in everyday life but i
don't have to go
we compete for a job but it's wack and
stupid to do it in front of tv
uh the apprentice it's slow because they
make you do some low estate yeah of
course you compete to have a record deal
but doing it for puff daddy having to go
get some milk from whatever whatnot and
what
is degrading and why because you're
doing in the competition and the fashion
that is why
my whole point is this is a reflection
on her
you know what i mean like if i was okay
let's say hypothetically right in some
alternate universe
i'm the best okay i got
10 girls
competing for me there are certain
things that i wouldn't co-sign or i
wouldn't want to be okay with
and they do give you quite a lot of
leeway in that regards so that's why i
think it reflects badly on her
the lack of tech in that regards that's
all i'm saying but you're right
they signed up for the show so there's
some element of it that they have to
expect
but i'm also not mad at his criticism
because he raises a good point but he
was petty and you know
like i said man listen guys if someone
wants you out just walk away you know
it feels good to get petty into it but
it doesn't set a good example
i think he's going to wash his back and
he's going to be not proud of some of
the things that he said some of it were
low blows
like the old age thing was not necessary
to say but
is there some truth to it sure but
doesn't mean that it's okay for you to
go for that
you don't always have to explain
yourself sometimes just walk away and
whatnot is this
you don't have to explain yourself okay
yeah i'm walking off but before i do so
i feel like i gotta let you know no
kiddo yeah i'm with him oh here's
something funny
the show ended halfway through the
season you wanna know why why because it
turns out when covert broke out and they
had to stop filming yeah
she was checking out like the guys at
social media the guys who are coming on
the bachelor and she actually fell in
love with one of the guys before the
show she never messaged him
but just seeing his social media pics
she fell for it really
yes and so during the middle of the show
she's like i don't want to continue more
i know who i want
so basically all those guys wasted their
time
so imagine this this girl
knew who she wanted from the chup made
them all look like idiots for a couple
weeks
and halfway through the show where they
wasted time away from their families to
be quarantined
all this other stuff she had already
chosen
who she wanted i hope that dude is like
nah i'm not feeling it no he's a you
know light skin
gotta do it
but anyways what was that look
you know how the my skin dudes pee no i
don't
[Music]
with your dusty ass you gonna look at
the camera with your big ass beard
trying to fake like you a light
[Music]
brother
all this to say yeah i think um she
approaches with a lot of uh
lack of respect for the other people
that were present and her even choosing
her person like what why you why are you
making us waste your time
in your head and how immature do you
have to be to choose someone based off
of social media
to marry for the rest of it like what
are we even talking about so
she's a lost case social media social
media
39 well how many more 39 how many
people want to marry you off of social
media yay
but she's 39
39 and and she don't know better
49. what's wrong with 39 i mean
hag i'm sorry no you have to put it
you have to say with a little bit of
grain in your head
well i know what you're talking about
that he said i'm
[Music]
what like can't do